From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, so today is Wednesday, April 17th. We are in Seattle, Washington. This is David Cline from Virginia Tech.
And the Smithsonian Museum of African American History and Culture, the Library of Congress, and the Southern Oral History Program.
Today, I am doing the interview along with John Bishop, who is our videographer of Media Generation and UCLA.
And today, we have with us Reverend Dr. Samuel Berry McKinney. And thank you so much for joining us today.
Thank you.
Reverend McKinney, if we could start, if you could tell us a little bit about your childhood, the family you were born into.
And I know that you were born into a church home with a strong civil rights background. So I'm curious to hear how that shaped you as you grew up.
My name is Samuel Berry McKinney, as was indicated. I was born December 28, 1926 in Flint, Michigan.
My father was a Baptist minister who was born in, outside of Gainesville, Georgia on July 19, 1892.
And he was one of 12 children. His father, Wade Hampton McKinney, and there was my father's name also, and my brother. And his son was a Georgia sharecropper.
We would move in, we would move into Georgia from South Carolina.
When my father was 18 and in the fifth grade, he was encouraged by his pastor of the St. John Baptist Church in Gainesville, Georgia.
The father of his education, he was 18 and in the fifth grade.
So he went to the Atlanta Baptist College in 1910, which became Morehouse College in 1914.
And I have somewhere, his high school certificate. Because at that time there were not many public high schools for blacks or color and negro, whatever we happen to be at that time.
And it was usually in the private sector of schools which were organized by many fair-minded people after the Civil War to educate the reason for the freedom of people bounding and slavery.
He, in 1916, received his high school diploma and in 1920. He graduated from Morehouse College with a B.A. degree.
He was accepted at the Rochester Theological Seminary in Rochester, New York, where he continued his education.
But let me back up just a little bit so you can get a flavor of what was going on at Morehouse at the time.
I indicated that there are many people who came south to try to help the people who recently freed from slavery.
In 1881, two sisters from...
I wanted to recall this first grade. We're rolling again.
So you were talking about Morehouse?
Yes. It was really organized in 1867. And it was a Augusta Baptist College. And then it moved to Atlanta and became Atlanta Baptist College.
And in 1914 it became Morehouse College, named for Henry Lyman Morehouse, who had been the executive of the...
It was then the Northern Baptist Convention, later to become the American Baptist Convention that we know today.
A lot of young people and many others came south white to join in that movement to train and educate many people.
Two young ladies came down from New England and then tried to think of the school they attended.
But they organized a college for women in the basement of the Friendship Baptist Church in Atlanta. And it became Spelman College.
They were modeled after the Harvard-Yale. I know they would have a university for men in a college for women.
And Spelman was the fittings of that category.
These two sisters, (Sophia B.) Packard and (Harriet E.) Giles, I can't remember their first names, called upon one of their schoolmates who had married Laura Spelman Rockefeller, to help fund this school.
And Spelman College was Spelman Seminary until 1929.
In 1929 there was quite a merger of schools in the country.
So many people appealed to Rockefeller for help.
He sat down and came over the Grand Master Plan instead of having all these schools where we can combine them and let's do so.
So that's where Union Seminary in New York came into being.
But in Atlanta there were several black institutions and they didn't lose any of their autonomy.
They were asked to work together in a unified fashion.
So the Atlanta University system was organized with the Morehouse as the component for men, Spelman, for women.
They were still independent. Atlanta University would be a graduate school and they had to fight to retain that name in Atlanta because others wanted that name to be more associated with white and black.
I'm saying all that to say that in 1916 a young lady from Birmingham, Alabama named Annie Ruth Berry McKinney McKinney, my mother, came to Spelman.
She was the youngest of six children and four girls all who had attended Spelman.
Spelman did not become a college until 1929.
I mentioned about the Rochester Theological Seminary in 1929.
It combined with Colgate. Colgate, a hundred some miles from Rochester, had a division of training ministers, were training ministers.
So it moved to Rochester and it became Colgate. Rochester beginning back to Spelman.
My mother ended up in Spelman Seminary in 1916.
She became one of 13 or 17 women who technically graduated from Morehouse, which was a college.
Spelman didn't become a college until 1929.
Rockefeller poured a lot of money into Spelman and it filtered out to the other schools.
My parents met on the campus because they had a lot of classes together.
Her background was a little different. My father came up for a boy's father was a sharecropper.
My mother's father was a Baptist minister and many of blacks at that time listened to Booker T. Washington who said to let down your bucket where you are".
let down your bucket where you are, build where you are, strengthen the land where you are.
And let your roots down, where you are, what it brought down to.
And many people in Alabama took that seriously.
My grandfather was one and he sent my own to a lot of land and gave it to his children.
I don't know what my mother did with hers, but when I asked about it she ignored me.
So in other words, we won't touch that.
But when Dr. King marched from Selma to Montgomery, every place he stopped along the way was on land that was owned by black people.
So he was not an intruder at any point.
And that was well-planned out.
Yes. And there are people who question and rightly so some of the philosophy of Booker T. Washington being as separate as fingers out but yet united.
He did not sit well with a lot of people and still does not.
But he didn't insist upon people looking out for themselves and owning land.
And this on the stem of grandfather did.
So my parents met there and my mother finished one of 13 or 17 women who technically finished the Morehouse.
And that was in 1921.
I was going to say, but you also at the same time you're talking about your grandfather on your mother's side.
He also insisted that sounds like that his children even had the same childhood as that in education.
Yes.
One son, the older son, went to Lincoln University in Pennsylvania, which at that time was like Morehouse All-Mail.
But it's co-ed now.
The next son, James, was sort of a rebel.
And I guess that happens in most families.
He stayed in Birmingham and worked for the Tennessee Iron and Coal Company.
They're in steel worker until he retired and passed.
So my mother's older sister, my mother's mother, died when my mother was two years old.
And so their older sister, who was 17 years old,
was feeling in help to rear her and set some standards for her.
And they became part of what some sociologists have called Black puritans.
Women and black women who were built against the notion that any black woman was fair, pray for any white man sexually.
They wanted to make sure that their children did not fall prey to that sort of doctrine.
And they stood for religious and moral purity in every way.
And so when my father asked my aunt for my mother's hand,
he had to jump through a lot of hurdles for her.
But she did live in 1829. She came to live with the family.
I'm saying all that.
And my mother also finished Columbia Teachers College and taught at what is now Jackson State.
It was Jackson College and Jackson Mississippi.
And then in the school that no longer exists Roger Williams College in Nashville, Tennessee.
And that's where she was teaching when she and my father married.
My father's first church was in Flint, Michigan, Mount Olive Baptist Church.
He went there in 1923.
They married in 1924.
My brother showed up in 1925.
I came along in 1926.
In 1928, my father was called to the Antioch Baptist Church.
A church he served for 34 and a half years until he passed in January, 1963.
Although he was the retirement, the end of 1962, he passed 18th of January, 1963.
He served that church well.
But going back to his college,
the only places where the blacks who attended the Abidic schools could teach were in the historically black colleges.
And so the persons who were able to get an education at the Abidic schools had to go south.
And many of them brought their ideas and things they had been exposed to.
One of the strong things that came into Morehouse was the emphasis upon social justice,
making society better and making people better and abiding people to stand erect on their feet.
So Dr. John Hope, who was president of Morehouse for many years,
I think he was president during my father's 10 years.
He looked like a white man and some people thought he was.
So he was able to walk a whiteer than the B.C.P. to move through some circles and societies
and some people didn't even know he was there.
They were looking for this colored man.
He was looking too, but they just set some standards.
They were then planned within this school, a desire for justice, the best training possible.
So the emergence of somebody like Martin Luther King Jr. was not a surprise.
So that's when my father came up and what he was exposed to.
Was there rooting in the social gospel?
Yes.
And they...
How would you describe what that means, what the social gospel is?
It means seeing...
It's based upon, in the Old Testament, this 61st chapter of Psalms,
is what Jesus quoted and is recorded in the fourth chapter of Luke of the Spirit of the Lord God is upon me
because he is anointed me to preach the gospel, to free the captives, to set at liberty of those who are bound to declare the acceptable year of the Lord.
And after Jesus read that in his hometown, he closed the book up and handed it back to the attendant and said today,
this has been fulfilled in your hearing.
During that period when my father was in college, there was a fellow who taught a roucher,
a roucher theological seminary for a while, a Walter Rauschenbusch.
You heard of that name.
He was declared one of the apostles of the social justice,
gospel, setting it in liberty, freeing up people who have been bound and to declare the truth.
And so my father came up under that kind of instruction, although Rauschenbusch died while he was still a student.
Rauschenbusch Mark was left on quite a number of the students and others.
And the person who became president of Morehouse four years before I entered there was Dr. Benjamin Elijah Mays,
who was out of South Carolina, (Bates?) Virginia (?), Bates College, then Union Theological Seminary, and then earned the PhD from University of Chicago.
And he was a president when I was there.
I was entered in 1944.
And at age 17, when I became 18, Uncle Sam was on me, and I tried to avoid it,
the process of escaping wasn't as defined as it is now.
One of the classmates, one of the fellow freshmen, was a fellow from Atlanta, a little fellow,
because of him.
Squirt, named Martin Luther King Jr. was in the same freshman class.
He was 15.
I'm not saying anything from him, but he was able to enter college at that age because World War II was on.
Students and enrollments were down, and especially in an all male institution.
We as freshmen noticed that we're over 400 of us, and only 50 of a classmate.
So some of us decided there would be no hazing.
No freshmen, we had numbers.
We had the numbers to back it up.
But in the state of Georgia, they came up with the idea to boost enrollments that if you,
and it wasn't limited to men, that if you took a test in the 11th grade and passed it,
you could go automatically, you could bypass the 12th grade and go directly into college.
And that's what Dr. King did.
It's just the Christine King Farris King Farris King Farris, who's the only surviving member of the family,
was right on time with her entrance.
So the college is the same time and graduated at the same time.
What was 15-year-old Martin King like?
I guess any other 15 year old, but he was what they called a city student.
He lived in the city, and he was driving a car before a motion.
So he drove to the campus.
It's interesting to note that to my knowledge, he took part in every oratorical contest and never won.
That's kind of hard to believe, but it happened.
He then went to Crozer Theological Seminary right outside of Philadelphia.
And from that, Boston University, and we have talked about it and laughed about it,
I had the opportunity to go to the church in Montgomery before he did.
And that's only ought to be lay up for the movement.
It didn't happen because I did not have, at that time, a commitment to nonviolence.
I grew up in Cleveland, Ohio. I was 18 months old when my father went there.
And it was there that I saw him speak out against injustices.
Work on programs and efforts to open doors for people in the same spirit of the social justice movement.
If there was injustice, he just didn't turn you back and walk away from it.
You adjusted it, at least undressed it.
So people could see it and know about it.
Your father had hosted some great minds at his church in Oakland.
He was about every few minutes and said, okay, we're back.
Was just as curious who came as guest to your father's church.
Well, he had people like A. Philip Randolph, Walter White of the NAACP.
Many people of that statue of the Mordecai Wyatt Johnson who was president of Howard University at that time,
and also a more house graduate.
And sort of a mentor, older brother figure, to my father when he was in college.
He had people like that, so I heard a lot of these people growing up.
And there was an organization, Future Outlook League. stood for Future Outlook League,
that had campaigns in Cleveland that don't patronize places where you cannot work.
And that challenged a lot of people.
They had milkmen back in that day.
You know, left a bottle of milk on a broad doorstep.
But the boycott of that until he broke down the...
Early boycott.
The challenge of Cleveland Transit System, just before World War II broke out and hired people.
I remember a lot of buildings big, you know, to bond like buildings.
I didn't know what they were.
When World War II started, all the lights went on.
And they were producing things for the war effort.
And a lot of people went to work.
There was another massive influx of people from the South.
And my parents were part of that when they called one of the first major round World War I to take part in the movement of Northwood.
In fact, no father was in the army for 59 days.
So it's England and the World War I.
And long enough to get some benefits from that.
They approximate what it was like after World War II.
That's the best G.I. Bill that the country has had.
I think if you can disrupt people's lives and put them into the least you can do is to give them an education or a job or something.
My brother and I were both able to finish college on the G.I. Bill.
So you were just talking about you being drafted and you ended up in the Army Air Corps?
It was Army Air Corps. The Air Corps, it's now Air Force.
It's a separate unit.
But the G.I. Bill was, if you were in military service on September 2, 1945 when the war officially ended, you were entitled to one full year on the G.I. Bill.
After that, one month for each month you were in service, not to exceed 48.
So that made it possible for my brother and I both to finish college on the G.I. Bill.
And my father could save his money from assistors when they went to college.
Could I ask a little bit about what it was like serving in the segregated military at that time?
It was what I'm describing like this.
I was in a segregated Army the whole time I was there.
After we had finished basic training at Sheppard Field, Wichita Falls, Texas, we were shipped to some of us, we shipped to the Yuma, Arizona.
And the train took a security route to get from Wichita Falls.
It went far west then, south to El Paso, then across New Mexico, Arizona.
But we did stop, it'll come to me, down in West Texas, where we stopped, the train stopped and we got off for lunch break.
This was in pre-plastic days.
We had cardboard plates wooden forks and somebody said, hey, come here and look.
We looked from where we were in the colored dining room, in the white dining room.
There were tablecloths, then in the silverware and German prisoners of war.
Sitting down to the table eating, we had on the United States Army uniform.
And these were supposed to be enemies of our country, because they were white.
That's how they were retreated, where they were treated.
And no respect for us, and I asked somebody, I was up-sid with what I saw.
I asked somebody, how far was it from where we were to Cleveland?
They said about 1800 miles.
And they asked me, are you thinking about going AWOL?
I said, I'm thinking about going AWOL.
That sums up a good bit of a re-wrapping the army, but in a segregated unit in the air force.
And on the basis where we were, well, if you want an air force base.
And in an listed person, you did not have to salute anybody under captain, because you had to be an officer to fly a plane.
And you'd been walking around like that all the time, but except when they made new loose ends.
And they made the last class, or you know, when we were there, sure that we got there.
Somebody said, land a bicycle, what?
They said they had the habit of giving a dollar to the first enlisted man who saluted them.
So you should have just said, you have to be a dollar with this hand.
But they had people assigned to the various units based upon what they did.
For instance, if you were a mechanic on the land, they all stayed together, except they had what they called a squadron F.
Where all the blacks, whatever they did, had to stay there.
And I found out I was part of the overhear for the squadron F.
It was not a good or happy feeling.
And no one respected us with the uniform on.
Go with on and off to the base. Did you get to go after me?
Oh yeah, yeah. But they had in town the colored USO, white USO, and had to stay there.
We went to a ship from Arizona to the biggest field, California.
And we discovered one thing, we could hit the ride into town.
You had no trouble getting from town back to the base.
But there were a lot of southern whites up in that area.
Also, we would land up outside the gates, you know, and you'd drive away from.
And I noticed that one night I was the only person left out there.
Most of the colors were from places in the south.
And most of these whites were to get in here.
And I found when I said I was from Ohio, I was left out on the road.
And I said, well, the next color comes by here, I'm going to be from Mississippi.
And that's what I said, getting in here from Mississippi.
And he asked me questions, I couldn't answer.
I asked him so I'd fake sleep.
And he found I asked where I was getting out of that toilet.
But they stopped shipping blacks of color, but we were known as then to Europe.
And then stopped shipping us overseas.
I mean, over to Asia as well.
And then we would ship from the biggest field of California all the way across country down to Florida.
And people were reenlisting so fast that I didn't notice when I first went in that the regular army on payday.
The regular army was paid first.
And then the more people that re-enlisted, the further back, the lowest private in the regular army was paid before the top civilian army as they called it other army of the US.
That's what most people were doing during the war.
And we finally came up with some things.
And one of them was everybody drafted in 1945 had to be out by Christmas of 1946.
So I was able to figure out how much time I had left.
And when back to school, I didn't have enough time to start all over again.
So I was in a pre-law track.
So I followed that until I graduated from college.
And I went to Colgate Rochester, Divinity School, and Rochester, New York for three years.
Did you think you would pursue the law at one point?
I was at plan to be a lawyer.
But then Morehouse was a historic religious institution so there was a required course in Bible that was taken.
George Kelsey.
I don't know.
Sometimes people say you're preaching to me.
I didn't know but he was speaking to me.
In fact, a lot of fellows were thinking about being lawyers.
And some of them were considering the ministry and how were they going to reconcile the two.
And then he said, the law can only function after something has been done.
For instance, as a woman who's complaining about being harassed,
brutalized by a husband or male friend, and the police will say,
well, I can't help you until he hurts you.
Sometimes it's too late.
He said, the law functions on the back end, religion functions on the front end.
And as one thinks so, one is, thought proceeds action.
And somehow I couldn't shake that or the analogy that he used it.
What should you do?
Put an ambulance in the valley to take people after they've fallen over the cliff to the hospital or put a pothole.
So people don't fall off.
Well, that resonated.
And I couldn't shake that and understand that had an impact on others as well.
Did you get to know Dr. Mays, as well?
He influenced quite a number of us.
He told us, when we first got to school and there were a lot of World War II was on,
there were a lot of white women who were driving buses and street cars and he told us
not to get into any argument, but if we had a problem with the person male or female,
make a mental no quickly of their name and badge number and get off and come back and tell him about it.
And we did. We found out that his contacts in New York and Atlanta has really been outposted.
Benjamin Elijah Mays was president of Morehouse from 1941 to 1967.
And not only kept these traditions of high scholarship and speaking of truth and justice,
but he modeled a lot of it.
And there were those who said that anybody who had come up in the school under Dr. Mays could have done what King did.
And he just agreed with that because when we were growing up, Joe Louis was a heavyweight champion.
A lot of people, they were riding on his face and his victories.
The mother sister, Anita, our totals, was caught up in this puritanical thing of her.
She felt that boxing was sinful.
And then I told you know, Joe Louis was born in Alabama.
Then she was from Alabama. She still didn't like it, but she listened to it.
When he was fighting, it was like a nice warm summer day.
People found the longest extension cord and would bring the radio, this before television, out of the front portion.
You could walk them down the street and not miss a thing.
It was going on the same thing happened when Jackie Robinson went into the baseball.
I grew up in Cleveland, which was in the American League. And Larry Doby was the first black.
He was on Cleveland, seen many American League. You would walk up in down the street and not miss anything.
When Joe Louis knocked the (Max) Schmeling out, we had an ex-dome neighbor who, in my aunt, were very good friends.
They thought alike. She got out on the front porch because she could have stand that sinful boxing.
And she had a sister who was visiting her from Mississippi.
And that lady had to wear close to 400 pounds.
she literally shouted the front porch down.
And we were pulling the porch back in the days. But she just was so happy.
Now a lot of blacks could not celebrate like that in the South.
A very kind and simple black man beating up a white man.
So...
But did people celebrate behind closed doors?
Oh yes.
But we arrived in the street and went back to the milling. It had been one of Hitler's boys.
So the Jewish community supported the celebrations of his defeat.
And this was an impactful time.
We had a famous neighbor who lived about five to six doors north of us.
I never saw him there, but his mother and father and younger brothers and sisters because of Jesse Owens.
They lived in Cleveland.
I never saw him in the house.
But you know it's the impact that they would have, but kids going up and down the street when they got in front of his house would stop on your mark.
You know, get set, go. He wanted to see you.
Run with that impact.
The presence was something.
And that's the kind of impact we had at that time.
We were still finding these various role models.
Yes.
And...
I think it was a very important door to the crew.
And they did...
Oh, it's for us, right?
For that?
Okay.
Yes.
I'm saying all this to say that I grew up in a community that seems at the...
to see the avenue YMCA and Cleveland.
That's how I had his hand on.
Or could it touch just about any black youth in the community?
And that was very, very helpful.
So when you went to seminary then, did you have a sense already what kind of a ministry you would be called to?
Yes, I am.
The models that I had had been folks like my father and some of his friends and liked Dr. Mays
And Mordecai Wyatt Johnson who was the president of Howard University was also a Baptist preacher.
And many of the folks I was exposed to, I didn't know them all, but many of those I was exposed to.
With those worth...with emulating.
And that's what I wanted to do, the idea of a megachurch.
Oh, that was unheard of then, although there were large churches.
And my father's church had...at the height of his ministry, had over 3,000 members.
And he would also bring, I think from 1936 through 46.
He brought for the church anniversary in January, Adam Clayton Powell Jr.
So got exposed to people like that.
Remember when he became the pastor of the church.
And when he was the next to the City Council in New York, then Congress.
So I was exposed to people of that nature that Dr. Mays would bring to the campus as often as he could people that he felt would be a great source of inspiration.
To the students.
So that's a good part of my life, I don't know which...
And did you stay in touch with Martin King after he went on the crotor you went on...
You went into the army or the Air Force and then on to Samaritan?
Yes, he...
He made one trip to Seattle at an invitation.
And that was the last time he traveled by himself.
Because he told me the near misses and escapes he had had.
He was sure that there were some assassins out there.
But after he came here, this was...
He said after his trip here was his last trip anywhere by himself.
We invited him here at the...
to speak of the brotherhood of the church.
And he accepted it.
And this was in 1961.
In 1962, we had a big world spare here in Seattle.
So what is now the Seattle Center was kind of under construction while that event.
So we knew that our facilities were too small to house in.
And the fellow who was the executive of the Presbytery of Seattle suggested that
I approach (First) Presbyterian Church, Seattle, which is downtown Seattle.
They had an old facility at that time that had seen it over 3000.
And we were given what I thought was a solid,
an antecedent agreement and understanding.
And then when we got closer to the time and started advertising,
I got a letter from the ruling body of the church stating that
you could not have the event there.
Because we had not followed the proper protocol and signing up to use it all of that.
So we asked for a meeting.
And we went to the meeting and several of the men from the church.
And the fellow who was the head of the church council of Presbyteria, whatever they called it,
I guess he was about six-two-and-a-half, flowing, you know, white hair, he was a lawyer.
We had the kind of boy that could strike fear in the judge and the jury.
You know you did not follow protocol.
You're going to do this or do the other.
And therefore you cannot have use of this.
So you understand that and we didn't answer.
But he said it anyhow.
And then he tried to soften his tone, said, but we know that you spend some money on your
advertisements and some other things.
I just give us a bill and we'll pay for that.
And I guess something rose up in me said, we don't want your money.
We didn't come down here.
We don't money.
We said, we never saw these documents that you said we refused to sign or didn't sign.
We didn't hear about them until you started broadcasting.
What you're doing, but we're not going to waste our time and your time.
The doctor came, will come.
He will speak.
And I said, we'll have to tell the world about what you did.
We'll tell the truth.
I said nothing but the truth, so help me God.
So help me.
God, we walked out and at that time,
he's been in Seattle and it's at the time.
Not any went the time.
How do I went to Seattle until 1967?
Oh, well, this was prior to I-5 going through downtown Seattle.
So the First Presbyterian Church up at 8th and Madison.
And we walked right down the hill to the...
Oh, what's that building?
It's Ac Deer to know.
But since then, the freeway has taken a strange route through downtown.
Took the properties that some people wanted to get rid of and get a good price wall.
But we went right down there and put money down on having the event there.
And it did happen there.
Just before I retired in 1998,
in the mail I had, there was an on-broad
and said, First Presbyterian Church.
And I looked at it and I tossed it in the circular pile.
And something told me to go back and look at it
because it wasn't a label on it was typed.
I said, well, what would these folks want?
And I opened it and the content of the letter was simply that
37 or 38 years ago, or even justice was done to your church
and to you and relish to apologize for that.
Well, I got it on the phone and called.
The minister told me I'd actually come down and be here.
He said, I think I'm a little younger than you all come up there.
Well, we had 19th and Madison.
There was 8th. Madison, so he came up.
And I told him, you know, a lot of whites say that this is unnecessary
because their ancestors never owned slaves
so we don't owe you an apology for anything.
That's what Summiff said.
And I said, you don't even apologize for white privilege.
The speed of certain things are automatically yours
because of who you are, but we appreciated what the young man did.
I don't think he's there now.
But he was just in...
He was at my retirement.
Ben Quid and I introduced him to the congregation
and others who were there.
And thanked him for what they set up some relationship
between the young people.
But it's as glad to see that something like that did happen.
If 38, 39 years later.
Yeah, better late than never.
But we still have to make correct and so it is.
It hasn't happened for over years ago, 100 years ago.
It is necessary.
And I'm still believing reparations
that don't have to be given me any money
but set up the Japanese were...
Because what happens to them is Pearl Harbor.
As a result of Pearl Harbor.
They've been apologies and financial things
because I was told we can see from up here
the wrench and Boeing Field
and understand that we're about to make several Japanese families
that own that land right of their farm in.
And it was taken away from them.
And down in Puyallup where they have a stake there.
That's where a lot of the Japanese who lived in the area
were herded right after Pearl Harbor.
And if you're going to apologize for that.
If you can say that you're sorry that...
And mean it means that you recognize
that injustice did take place.
And part of the healing process.
And that's part of being prophetic.
It's just not only calling...
focusing the spotlight on the injustices
that were done but also making it possible
for a healing to take place.
And forgiving and forgiveness is a part of the healing process.
And when that happens,
it will begin to get somewhere.
This is jumping ahead in time.
But do you remember James Forman's 1969 James Forman's 1969 Black Manifesto's James Forman's 1969 Black Manifesto?
In 1968, he called for reparations.
What did you think about that?
That call to the... that you're just listening to guys?
Yeah.
It was part of the...
I guess the evolutionary process of people's eyes
opening and recognizing that
holding people in slavery for 400 years.
And not batting in that about it.
And the South acting like a baby in the lose of civil war.
And this is a part of our culture.
And our heritage...
I have a problem with that.
And I still do.
There those who get over and I said,
we'll win.
You know, you might ask a mother question.
Let me ask you because we skipped a little bit.
So when you first came to Seattle to Mount Zion Baptist Church Baptist Church,
and then what kinds of social justice issues did you find
that needed to be worked on here?
Well, let me say that every part of the country
has been infected with the poison of racism
and the great cardinal assimilation has been.
And still is the matter of race.
We don't live in a post-racial world.
The white people who originally came out this area
from what I understand came from the Middle South.
At Tennessee Kentucky, maybe portions of Virginia,
down in Joe, Oregon, and up here.
There was a law that wasn't repeal until 1926
that he had discovered in America that made it illegal
to blackstrap permanently settle in the Oregon territory.
I didn't know about this till I moved out here.
Just putting it in historical perspective.
Thomas Jefferson was either the second or third race,
a third president.
Thank you, Mr. Thurard.
The great lover of black women
was approached by representatives of
who was the great French general?
No, no, no.
It became header-price, I say, for an exile.
Yes.
The Napoleon had someone approach Jefferson
and told him that he had access to land west of the Mississippi
where they had thought about establishing a new France.
But after the slaves and hated, yes, rebelled.
They had to get out of there real fast.
He was willing to sell it to them for 15 million.
He never said, put on, he never seen it.
Clark, those two fellas, came out here
and about 20 states were carved out of,
was the Louisiana Purchase.
And then the big, jumbling the size of the United States
and the big discussion was whether this would be free country,
a slave country.
And I understand partly, well, when I came out here
there was no I-5, but there was 99 Highway
was main therapy up and down the west coast.
And the portion of it going north of Seattle
up to the Canadian border was called Confederate Highway.
There was a man named George Washington Bush.
I don't think in relation to the bushes
that once occupied the White House
who led a wagon train of folks west from Missouri.
And when they got to, when they got to Portland,
they were told they couldn't jump permanently suddenly,
but they crossed the river to Fort Vancouver.
They could tell them about land that was being homesteaded
of round Puget Sound.
Let me fast forward a bit.
I had to speak to a group once in Washington,
or I think to Washington was somewhere up there.
The mountains and it had a happy hour,
something there was one fellow.
In hebreed it to the point of being obnoxious and all like that.
But before you speak, I want to know
what have blacks contributed positively
to the state of Washington.
I told him, now if you sit down and fasten your seat belt,
I guarantee you when I get through telling you that you'll be sober.
And he was quiet from that point on.
They had a process that you could not permanent
to sit in an Oregon territory.
But it was a slow, the boyish process.
The sheriff had escorted you from where he went to the next county.
It would take two years to get from there.
Like that. Well, I guess they got tired of enforcing it.
It wasn't repealed until 1926.
But there's...
I think that law, I try to live in Portland.
The parts of that law were still enforcing World War II
and they made exceptions to them.
So, the kinds of good-builder shipquins
that they were going to put themselves.
It was just real shocked to me when I woke there.
And that story.
Sorry, I didn't mean that.
No, no, no. You just told me something that
they stopped enforcing it to a degree
because it's too black searches in Portland.
I think Beth only in me and not a lot of good-baptists
organized in 1911.
So they stopped really enforcing it to a degree.
But George Washington Bush and his company crossed the Columbia
and they were told that there was land they could settle, homestead,
up around where the state capital is,
here around Lacey, Washington, Olympia.
But when they came up, a lot of people
I understand, started saying the neighborhood is changing.
And there had been some argument between Canada and United States
and Britain about what the northern boundary of the United States
would be.
And I guess it's the 49th parallel.
But they ran back so fast they committed with a
renman called Kakasort Errors.
There's a part of them, the Canadian mainland,
that just beneath the 49th parallel,
Point Roberts.
And the schoolchildren who lived there after travel,
30 miles, 1 way, 60 mile round trip,
daily to go to school in Whatcom County,
which is right on the Canadian border.
And the closest United States and Canada of Britain
came to a war.
After that was about the Pig War.
So, but one of George Washington Bush's sons
was in the last territorial legislature
and in the first state legislature of the state of Washington.
So I was able to tell this brother, I said,
now you all know what did we contribute.
If it hadn't been for this black man coming across the border,
the state of Washington could have easily become a part of British Columbia.
And if some people in the audience were correct.
But I'm saying all that by a way of background.
When I came in, there were a lot of people
who had come here from different parts of the country.
And this area was on the surface better than what they left.
Now, I came here and I received the call of that the latter part of November 1957.
But I moved in and began the first Sunday in February 1958.
I have something I, you know,
and I've passed it on to other ministers,
young ones, so it can maybe help them.
If they could find out where many of their members of their congregation migrated from,
I'd say they were a little bit,
I came here from, I passed it in Providence, Rhode Island,
for three years and three months.
And I ordered order was going there.
The people who migrated back during World War I were basically from Virginia.
During World War II, they were from North Carolina.
I grew up in Cleveland and that megatory pattern was parts of Georgia.
And Alabama definitely, and Kentucky, Tennessee.
And some people out of the western part of Virginia coming through
Rome, Oak, and the Columbus, Ohio.
Detroit drew people from a lot of places because of the car industry.
Chicago was the jumping ground of Mississippi.
And coming out here,
I discovered that most of the people who migrated here during World War II,
I'm not talking about the people that the military brought,
were from west of the Mississippi.
And Louisiana, Texas, Arkansas, Oklahoma.
And I, perhaps they haven't had, I'll see it anyhow.
I discovered that many of them were,
put them all backward.
And just checking it out, Dr. King never mounted a serious effort west of the Mississippi.
He received a lot of support from people in California and other places.
But I tried this up so I could get my hands on it with what I call the zoom-teenth factor.
You familiar with zoom-teenth?
I had never heard of zoom-teenth.
Until I was in Army and Texas and basic training and they,
they didn't shoot the zoom-teenth.
They gave us that day off and I said, what's this?
Now that's your emancipation day.
And then some of them thought I was crazy.
I said, from what?
It's just slavery.
And I said, well, we had, you know,
had we'd always celebrated January 1,
because Abraham Lincoln signed the emancipation proclamation,
which took effect January 1, 1863.
And many churches had what they call watch meeting services and the origin of that was people were gathered
and churches and other places counting off the time.
So in the clock struck midnight, 12 o'clock, 1863,
we were technically free.
Those in the states that were in rebellion against the United States.
Now the word did not get to Texas or they did not release the word until June 19th, 1865.
And then it didn't make sense for me to, you know, go off the base of celebration,
you're free to men.
That's the only time you could use the amusement park,
which you had to be out of there by 6 p.m.
Because we're kind of free to them.
There's that natural of some people.
And I was just teasing when I said it.
I now understand why you're so backward.
Two years later, the news working two years,
as a slave when you were free.
And then if you listen carefully to some of the people who were mad at Obama being a elected president,
they're talking about succeeding from the United States.
The governor of Texas raised that possibility.
But that's part of what the Civil War was about,
not necessarily freeing us, but about breaking up the union.
So we're not in a post-racial nation yet.
And I don't have to be angry and mad just think this.
So bringing people into the 21st century has not been easy.
I'm saying all of this to understand this place.
Yet with all the military facilities around the country,
prior to World War I,
there were only two Army forts on the stand where interracial mix couples could live.
Fort Lewis, Washington, 46 New Jersey.
Certainly not Fort Lewis, Texas, Fort Benning, Georgia.
They have seen since then.
So the things that brought people here,
our church was organized in 1890,
one year after the Washington became a state.
And so there were people here that somehow did we get here?
What brought them here?
There were some who were trying to get us far away as they could.
And here was a police right over there.
You saw the south end of a Mercer Island,
right up there in those hills.
There's a lot of coal.
I had to go over there to Sunset Hills Memorial Park today this morning,
for a grape-sciend service.
But we went by a street called Coal Creek Parkway.
That's just not a name and pull out of there to give a fancy feel to.
There is a lot of coal still.
Okay, I wouldn't know how to get back there now,
but some years ago I was taking up there and showing a mass grave.
And most of the people in there were from Wales, Scotland.
And they were all basically under 30.
And they had been a big explosion and a coal man up there.
So they were just cool up there,
right on the other side of the mountains.
There was a time called Roslyn in Washington.
And that's the police where I'm told.
A lot of blacks were brought into Roslyn as scab labor.
They could break the backs of the union.
And they had a couple of colors who passed on.
Now they told me that they were kids when they were brought out here.
And they left there and then ran over here in Kennedy,
there was a section of across the lake over there.
The Kennydale of the Rensham.
It was coal mining.
Kennydale, Washington.
K-E-N-Y-D-A-L-E.
And there's a vein of coal that runs right under it,
maybe where we're sitting now, right on out in the Puget Sound.
So then to see there were four (transcontinental) railroads that ended out here,
sitting lands across the Pacific.
All of these are things that brought people here,
many who came here for the, in the military state.
I church was organized, so I'm told,
by a group of people from the Memphis Tennessee area.
So it's interesting.
I forgot what it was you asked me.
When you got out here on the surface,
things seemed...
It appeared to be...
It appeared to be, but...
But I'm guessing there was something below this.
Yeah, there was.
I remember some places where we tried to eat.
And they had to remind them that they weren't where they came from.
They may not want to feed me.
And if they didn't want to feed me,
I didn't want to eat their food.
It happened because I don't know.
I know some of the things that were done.
In retaliation to that sort of thing,
I wouldn't want to eat any of the tainted food myself.
But there were...
We had difficulty finding houses at first,
not this one, but I didn't want to stay in the church process.
And we needed all of that to expand the church.
But I would call around to see what I'd seen in the Virgin Mary's house.
I wasn't calling and asking about it.
Somebody would ask me, are you colored?
I think you just asked straight out.
Yeah, maybe they could get out of my voice.
I tried to mask.
It belonged to my wife, Carl.
She was in education.
She was a purist when it came to language.
She was more English and a speech and pronunciation than the British themselves.
So then we saw so much time that when we showed up,
there was a different story.
So that was here.
That was right here in Seattle.
We did have...
We did have some strikes and other things against
the big department store downtown.
Years ago, it was Frederick & Nelson.
Nordstrom's now in the building where Frederick & Nelson was.
But when we marched on Frederick & Nelson,
that opened them up to employment.
Who were your allies in this kind of work?
Were Seattle organized at all?
Oh, yeah.
What was your urban age?
The NAACP.
There was...
Did CORE have a print of them here?
Later.
Yeah.
They had a presence later on.
But historically, the NAACP and...
And urban age on the ground so to speak.
What was it?
I know that in 1963, you were part of the group that organized what became known as the CACRC.
If you could tell us what that was.
What was that for?
This was the community group that drew from other groups to fully all to do.
To fully all together to organize the essential area.
Yeah, exactly.
I only wrote down that.
The essential area.
Central Area Civil Rights Committee.
Yeah.
That was made up of all the groups.
As a Rev. John Adams, who was the pastor first in me at the time,
was the most successful leader of that group.
He's now a retired bishop in the AME church living in Atlanta.
And did you quite a few things?
Has school strike?
You can stay at home from school.
The schools were segregated prior to that?
additionally.
They weren't the best.
They thought they were.
I'm a wife of Spanner Hill, Korea, here in Seattle in the school district.
Yeah, it was under the auspices of the Central Area Civil Rights Committee that a lot of good was done in organizing the museum.
And people.
And we really had two fronts.
One was working in harmony with groups that were struggling in the South
and also dealing with whatever vestiges of segregation and racism we encountered here.
Someone said at that time the difference between the South and the North,
the South didn't care how close blacks and whites got so wrong,
we didn't get too high.
The North didn't care how high we got provided we didn't get too close.
So I think that sums it up to a great extent.
They had a state.
The state had a group.
I'm trying to think of it.
I'm not trying to say it's a private name, but the last part was against racial discrimination or something of that effect.
And they would deal with things legally.
They were kind of slow in.
Of course you had to prove that you had really been mistreated.
So there was a need for other kinds of activities.
But I think the big march on.
Frederick & Nelson really opened up a lot of George R. Remember one fellow.
He was a member of our congregation.
He was had a critical of me and my participation.
And told us we shouldn't march against Frederick & Nelson.
But when we did it and was successful, he was one of the first persons to apply it for a job.
There's always going to be some people who think you're too radical.
And then there's others who think you're not radical enough.
And so I know that towards the end of the 60, 68, 69, there were some more radical groups that began to deform and see out including a chapter of the Black Panther.
And how did you all work with them or had it?
Not too well.
Go ahead.
What was the access to Congress?
Could have been a generation, could have been a...
thought we were moving too slow or some of their white supporters.
We felt that we needed to get out the way so they could come more to the poor.
And some of us tried to ignore it because it looked like somebody tried to play off one group against the other.
And they hadn't gotten up off of anything.
And I think the Panthers could have been more effective than they were.
Did you understand where they were coming from or at all?
Did it seem like just the wrong approach to you?
I thought that they were coming from.
Then some of them saw the ministers as they entered more than discrimination.
And some of us were the targets of some of their anger and venom.
But some of them were matured, grown up.
But they're still here.
Time moves on.
Can you tell us a little bit?
I think we'll probably wrap up pretty soon.
But about some of your other work, your later work.
And particularly interested in your work with Liberty Bank or the Industrial Center.
And I know that there's now the Samuel Berry McKinney Manor.
If you could tell us about that.
One of the things I know when I came, one of the things that interested me was that the church wanted to build.
That's something I wanted to do.
So those two things can hook up.
We can go forward.
We need to buy up some land that we did.
And we were able to build a new church by our land so we could have parking so much city.
If a church can park the cars and babysit the children, you can grow them.
Otherwise, they will plateau.
So we tried to do that.
And we looked at our sister church down the street, first seeing me that now completely surrounded by apartments.
People coming back to the city who ran away from it.
That's what gentrification is all about.
I was talking about poor whites coming back.
This is gentry.
We know the difference.
And we were able to Mount Zion Baptist Church Baptist Church (to) buy quite a bit of property.
And I think that hated in the...
I have them.
So one of the first things I did when it came was to set it up so the church could back the land.
We also established a credit union in the church.
So people could take care of their own needs and also when we got ready to build the sanctuary unit,
we didn't get money from one single local bank.
So we did have the help of the American Baptist Home Mission Society as well as people borrowing from the credit union.
So the local banks just flat-out refused?
Yeah, on that part.
But then we took advantage of some of the government programs and that's how we were able to build the manner.
Now another piece, it's 22nd and Jackson.
It's a Seattle Vocational Institute.
But that venue was initially the Seattle OIC Opportunities Industrialization Center.
That after President of that, Dr. Rev. Leon H. Sullivan of Philadelphia started that movement,
the training that educate people.
We put up that building.
But when (President Ronald) Reagan became President, he pulled a rug out from under.
A lot of those community efforts set better themselves.
And Jim McDermott, who's a representative from the state, stepped in
and where we were on the verge of bankruptcy, he had the state to take over.
That didn't give that to wipe out any debt that we owed and also to the community colleges
to have their facility, which is there now.
They also, another program, a CAMP.
And now there are others who have come to take it over and change the name from Camp to Setahoe.
They say they're there to help the new poor.
Setahoe.
Or something like that.
So I've been involved in a lot of those community efforts.
I was a part of the group that helped organize the Liberty Bank,
which later went out of business and the facility that it built in 24th and union.
I rode by that a day, I made being a living trouble.
Because they said they were going to close that facility.
And they got a safety deposit box.
And I don't know what it's going to happen to.
Tomorrow I'm going to get on that very thing.
So I have been involved in doing what I feel is a lot of good around the city and community.
Not only protesting, but also building.
And you see all these different kinds of works on different fronts as connected as part of the same body?
Yes, and one of the questions, one of the problems we have to face now is how you have community
when you no longer have neighborhood.
I'm looking at how the Jewish community has dealt with that and some of the Asian communities,
where they are scattered and may not.
There are some points where they are united.
I know I spoke at the church.
I speak annually. They called it Passing Maritra Sunday, but there was a couple of years ago.
When I was speaking at the I did just hit me.
I asked how many of you live within a mile of the church.
And the further I got away from there, here we are, it's in my house.
The more people we encountered.
And I began to think about that.
It would have been the opposite when the church was first.
Well, no.
The church moved to 19th and Madison in 1920.
And the built in old, built in essentially there.
Then we replaced in 1974.
We put an education here at first, but there were those who ran from the neighborhood.
But historically, there were two areas.
One off of Madison, 2425, was a pocket of blacks and then over on Jackson,
was another pocket.
And I've seen those two grow together, which are called the other central area.
Now, but I think there were some who were glad to see it change because
too much political power was being assessed, was being developed there.
Many of the churches are there. There's something that's springing up in other places.
But that was a historical community.
And I noticed that on Sunday we have people, members who live out this way in North-Answer.
And after church they like to mix them being able to, because I haven't seen,
folks that they used to see at the grocery store don't see them anymore.
In fact, when I first came up on another method of ministries of people,
there were several credit, good-sized supermarkets in the central area.
And sometimes when I was in some of them on business people would come up to me
from the church to ask questions or someone said,
I won't be there soon to put this in here as my offering,
to put in.
And so I just started some Friday evenings and early Saturdays just hanging around the supermarket.
And people would be very, very come up.
But they've torn up a lot of that.
And the largest number of blacks moving into the central area now
are from various sections of the African continent.
So that's it just before I retired.
I was asked to come to a meeting.
And you know how some people are when they think they have a heavy drop on you.
Do you know that African Americans are now the number three non-white group in the community?
And other things I was supposed to, I guess I was supposed to have been stressed out on the floor crying and hungry.
And if he'd gone through that, he wanted a reaction because he, I don't think he was getting the one.
He expected, I said, well, first of all, you say that his panics are now the largest single group.
I said, but the thing that unites the Hispanic community as unsuspecting is not ethnicity but tone.
So you have a lot of black Hispanics.
Now how do you figure that? How do you deal with that?
Well, that wasn't what he was expecting.
And I said, now you're comparing us.
All the blacks against, no, no.
One segment of the blacks against, like all the Asians.
And all the, that's on Latinos and Hispanics and not all.
The United, depending upon where they came from.
But part of Mexico they came from, where they came from, Chile, Argentina, Cuba.
Say all of those things figure in.
And then we talked about the, the people from the various parts of the African continent.
I said, Africa is not a country.
It's a continent.
And you have as many varying differences of known blacks as you do, known, known whites.
How do you know all of this?
I said, how do you feel?
I said, you know what, you claim you know.
And we just want to set the record straight.
So you, you know what's going on.
I told them that some of the Ethiopians,
before they built a, that church had certain events in our church.
So I was aware of this mall, but for Haitian churches in West Seattle.
I said, well, you didn't know that.
But what is the Central Area is very desirous.
It's a piece of property.
My wife found this place.
But I was setting people on.
I said, you're property in the Central Area is valuable.
Then I kept a mailbox up there in the 23rd Union in the east.
Once a week or twice a month someone said to me, aren't you the fellow that told us not to sell our property?
I said, yes, but you left.
I said, well, did you see the picture of the Godfather?
I said, yes, and I was given an offer I couldn't refuse.
So we, in 1958, moved away with you there for 42 years on in the Madrona.
And then my wife found that we needed another place.
She found this.
And if a wife is happy, you can make it.
That's a picture right there.
She passed in August.
But...
And was a real partner of yours in your ministry and after that?
If she had a own life and education, I didn't fool with...
She was the expert there.
And she found this place.
And left a mark on it.
The people we bought the house from, we know them.
They came back one day and they didn't recognize it.
She put these floors in.
The windows.
Because they used to rattle them.
They first came in.
Got a nice view here.
Well, anything that we didn't talk about or that I didn't ask,
they would like to...
I can rattle them.
Well, what could it be some areas that you feel
that you should have been touched to deal with it?
I think we covered quite a lot.
I know, but I made a list.
Some of the main things.
Well, you have a long perspective on the movement.
What's happening in your wife's time.
Can you say something about what progress has been made
or what still needs to be done?
A lot of progress has been made.
Some people feel that Obama's election should sum it all up.
But I have never seen or expected some of the reaction.
Some of the things that have been said about Obama
that if they've been said about Bush who I feel was the worst president
we've ever had from the beginning up to this time.
They tolerated him and Obama is bent over too much after he ever tried to plaking.
Folks who have no intention of working with him
because they would rather see the country suffer than for him to claim any credit.
It's been a good that has been done.
And I just want to...
I think you could take a couple of pages from Roosevelt's book.
You don't cooperate.
You're just...
We'll suffer.
I can see people now trying to get into the position to play blacks and Latinos off one against each other.
But that's an old trick and...
Many things were pulled to tragedy feet of Obama
but they did not count on the coming together.
The folks they ignored and still think that they can just talk to them
and talk to other groups and they were born in with them.
The Asian communities are some of the most highly trained and educated in the country.
And you can't buy them or would be yes.
You have to put a percent up and it's becoming more that way with some of the Hispanic Latino communities.
And we need to all come together and find out who really wants to go in the direction we feel is best for the nation.
And I think they found out that many of the people 30 in London have more in common.
Than the Tea Party as whoever they are.
It's interesting it's going to be more interesting as we go along.
And I'm just curious to where Obama is going to take us.
I'm really going to go along with him.
And I think most people who think for a capable of thinking would you likewise?
I also had the feeling that there were those who say that we experimented in the backman was president now.
It's time for a woman to be president.
I'm sure that Mrs. Clinton would make a good president.
That's the way we're headed.
And I think we are.
There's hope for us.
And I'm just praying every day that the nuts and the fools out there.
We feel their lives depend upon the right to have a gun and shoot it.
Or be seen with one or come to their senses.
I'm just praying that since which is not common to everybody, we'll prevail.
So what are you going to do with all this stuff?
Well, it's going to, well first of all, we just thank you very much again for sharing your story with us.
I'm for your work.
The material is all going to go into the Library of Congress.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.